and two don't you
void
the online world has improved great many
things it's easier to search classified
ads it's easier to find out of print
books and if you wish to see any two
cartoon characters having sex you need
only ask however there's one area where
I think even the most forward-thinking
technophile would agree we've gone too
far we've sucked the humanity out of
something that was once vibrant and
personal and I'm speaking of the realm
of the con man in the Golden Age of
hucksterism an unsavory gent might sell
you a bridge or a parcel of swampland or
perhaps a simple faux Stradivarius
violin whatever it was they would do it
by first getting your confidence the con
and con man they would become your
friend the old-fashioned way by erecting
a pile of lies with as much care and
craft as a roman architect and when they
departed taking your money and your
ability to trust humanity with them you
could take solace in the knowledge that
this was your con carefully customized
to your particular special kind of
gullibility what do you get now in
personal email form letters handed out
like ads for hookers on the Vegas strip
cold distant warnings of fictional ebay
disputes mindless soulless pop-up ads
for products that when downloaded just
give you more mindless soulless pop-up
ads the soul of yesteryears con man may
have been shriveled and caustic with
disdain for his fellow man but at least
he had a soul can a computer cackle with
glee as it fans its face with a stack of
bills taken from your bank account well
yes it can but only if specially built
for the purpose and I don't think
today's swindler is going to take the
time and the stories it used to be that
a con man would leave you with the tale
to tell passerby as you held out your
hand asking for a few meager coins the
Spanish princess in need of a brave
young man to act both as her rescuer and
her husband the briefcase that appeared
to be full of money until you got your
hands on it at which
when it contained only newspaper the
betting shop bustling with people all of
whom is it turns out we're in on the
scam they may have taken your money but
they left you with a tail that was worth
mmm maybe a 50th of what you lost today
of course you're lucky if you get a few
run-on sentences about nigerian royalty
more likely you're just going to end up
with a story about trying to sell a
laptop on ebay and getting a cashier's
check in payment how are you going to
get free drinks with the tail like well
this website asked me to put it my login
and password so I put in my login and
password it lacks epic sweep gravitas
adventure tragedy well there's tragedy
for you but nobody else cares I call
upon the grifters schemers and flim-flam
artists of this brave new age to step up
their game don't just throw form up in
my face get to know me befriend me and
then present me with a deal so juicy
that I'd run out and tell all my friends
if I weren't afraid that they'd take
advantage of it instead and then when
the time comes rip out my heart take my
money and tip your hat to me as you say
goodbye anybody can cheat me but only
you can truly con me
you